(notification whistles)
- [Reporter] This is why Twitter
has $13 billion in new debt
that it took on at the end of 2022.
Elon Musk didn't start Twitter's problems.
It hadn't booked an
annual profit since 2019,
but in the months after that tweet,
its finances have drained.
Revenue fell an estimated 40%
year over year in December.
Still, Musk is projecting optimism.
- [Musk] I think we've got a shot
at being cash flow positive next quarter.
- [Reporter] But just
how possible is that?
Let's look at Twitter's cash flow before
and after Musk's takeover to
see how its revenue has changed
and why he insists Twitter
will take flight again soon.
Twitter's cash flow problems started
before Musk's takeover of the company.
It had posted a loss in
eight of the last 10 years.
- The last full year that
we have figures for is 2021.
They booked about 5 billion in revenue
and also booked about
5.5 billion in costs,
which goes to show that
the company's finances
even before the takeover
were a little stressed.
- [Reporter] But for
the money it was making,
it relied heavily on advertising.
Take a look at the second quarter of 2022.
Advertising accounted for more
than 90% of Twitter's revenue.
Fast forward to October
when Elon Musk purchased
Twitter for $44 billion.
(Musk shouts)
That buy saddled the company
with that $13 billion in debt.
Analysts estimated at the time
that this would put Twitter
on the hook for annual interest payments
of more than $1 billion
compared to 51 million in 2021.
- The debt is going to drain
the company's resources.
He added a huge burden to
the company's finances.
- [Reporter] Musk came in
with big ideas for Twitter,
including cutting down its
reliance on advertising revenue
and focusing on subscription services.
But one idea that he focused heavily on
was promoting what he
refers to as free speech.
Musk began reinstating accounts
that had been banned for
tweets that violated policies
and limiting content moderation.
- Twitter has become a little
bit more of a chaotic platform
and place since Elon took over.
- [Reporter] Last year saw a
slowdown in online marketing
that affected many platforms
due to people spending less time online
and broader economic concerns.
But Twitter had additional issues
because some of Musk's
changes didn't sit well
with some big advertisers.
Within weeks of the takeover,
companies including Chipotle
and United Airlines had pulled back
or paused their ad
spending on the platform,
hurting Twitter's primary
source of revenue.
- Advertisers are really
focused on brand safety
so that when their ads appear online
or anywhere for that matter,
they want want to know
that the content that it's surrounding
is not offensive or not inflammatory.
- [Reporter] Musk has said Twitter
must be a respectable
platform for advertisers,
and Twitter says brand
safety is a priority.
While advertisers fled,
Musk was taking stock of his new company.
He said in early November
that Twitter was losing $4 million a day.
- Because I'm just thinking
about like, how do we...
I'm just like, you know,
just get Twitter to be in a
financially healthy place.
- The main way that's being addressed,
we're told, is through cost cutting.
- [Reporter] Twitter went
from about 8,000 employees
before the sale to
around 2,000 in December,
but these job cuts have
come with their own price.
- When you fire whole teams
and take them off the site,
suddenly there are
people who had expertise
in running a very complicated machine
that are not around anymore,
and it's not a surprise
that there have been
unexpected unplanned outages.
- [Reporter] Twitter hasn't
said much about recent outages,
but the company responded
to a request for comment with this.
(message beeps)
Aside from cost cutting,
Twitter has made moves to grow revenue.
- Please subscribe to Twitter
Verified, eight bucks,
and actually it's technically,
it's 7.99, so slightly less.
- [Reporter] In December, it relaunched
its paid subscription
service Twitter Blue.
As of March, it's estimated
that the subscription service
has about 450,000 users
according to Travis Brown,
a software developer who
tracks social media platforms.
Now Twitter Blue is $11
for mobile phone users.
- We haven't seen a big
uptake of Twitter Blue yet.
There aren't enough incentives yet
or reasons to join Twitter
Blue to cause a mass signup.
- [Reporter] So Musk is also
appealing to advertisers
to come back to the platform.
- [Musk] What I'd say to
advertisers and brands is,
you know, use Twitter yourself
and believe what you see on Twitter
not what you read in the newspapers
'cause what you see on
Twitter is the real thing
and what you read in newspapers is not.
- [Reporter] Currently, Musk
says the company earns five
to six cents an hour spent
by its users on the platform,
an amount Musk isn't satisfied with.
Still, he sees potential saying...
- [Musk] There will be a
massive increase in revenue
because it is now useful.
- He sincerely believes that
through targeted advertising
more specific forms of content
instead of just general ads
for the public writ large,
advertisers will spend
more because they feel
like they're reaching their
target audience on Twitter.
- [Reporter] But are these efforts enough
to actually make that happen?
One analyst says the company
could at least break even
in nine months based on
estimates of recent cost cuts
and stabilizing ad revenue.
Twitter could also negotiate
down its interest payments,
and Musk could contribute
more of his personal wealth.
But whether the company books a profit
depends on what direction Musk takes.
- He wants to turn it into
like an everything platform
where you can essentially
integrate commercial activity
with reading the news,
with talking to friends.
And I think that's the long-term vision,
but first he's gotta be
sure that the company
can pay its bills, and that
is still a bit in question.
(soft instrumental music)